ومن بولندا مشاهدينا اعرب الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن عما سماه التزام بلادها الثابت
تجاه اوكرانيا وتجاه سيادتها واكد ان
الدعم الامريكي لكياس سيبقى راسخا
وديمقراطيه ستنتصر حتما ولا يمكن باي حال
التسامح مع الحكام المستبدين حسب تعبير
بعيدا
لقد كانت سنه استثنائيه تميزت بوحشيه غير
عاديه من القوات الروسيه والمرتزقه لقد
ارتكبوا جرائم ضد الانسانيه دون خجل او
رافه استهدف المدنيين بالقتل والتدمير
واستخدموا الاغتصاب سلاحا في الحرب واريد
ان اتحدث مره اخرى الى شعب روسيا الولايات
المتحده ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي لا تسعى
للسيطره على روسيا او تدميرها الغرب لم
يكن يخطط بمهاجمه روسيا كما قال بوتين
اليوم ملايين الروس الذين يريدون العيش في
سلام مع جيرانهم ليسوا اعداءنا الحرب لم
تكن ابدا ضروره انها ماساه الرئيس بوتين
اختار هذه الحرب يمكنه انهائها بكلمه
الامر بسيط اذا توقفت روسيا عن اجتياح
اوكرانيا فستنتهي الحرب واذا اوقف
الاوكرانيون مقاومتهم لروسيا فستكون نهايه
اوكرانيا